welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman today you
can follow me on twitter by the way
at farren balanced you can also find me
on facebook and instagram at
fair and balanced i'm on youtube
youtube.com slash
the ring of fire and youtube.com slash
fahren balanced now we've got a bit of
an issue here right
if you've been paying attention to the
news this week you have no doubt
seen a little bit of speculation
about marjorie taylor greene possibly
running for president and the reason
these stories have been
popping up throughout the week is
because it was recently announced
that marjorie taylor green on august
19th i believe it is
is about to make a trip to the iowa
state
fair and for those of you who may not
know the significance of the iowa state
fair
you know how every primary season we get
the photographs of
candidates and they're chowing down on
the big old corn dogs and
meeting with people yeah that's usually
from the iowa state fair this is
essentially the launching
ground of many presidential campaigns
they go to iowa at this state fair which
is massive
to test the waters to gauge the response
of the individuals in attendance
and marjorie taylor green is gonna go
there
so it has prompted this speculation as
to oh my god
is she actually thinking of running for
president this
person who's been in office for eight
months now
already been stripped of her committee
assignments and now she might be running
for president and to that i say
hold your horses folks now she may be
running for president i'll get to that
in a minute
but let's not jump to those extreme
conclusions just yet
okay we know that for the last several
months marjorie taylor green has been
touring the united states
with matt gates they've been going out
spewing election lies attacking
democrats attacking republicans
attacking the deep state
attacking quite possibly anybody that
they think is going to benefit them
politically by attacking
we also know that in the recent weeks
they've kind of struggled to find venues
right
got kicked out of three different places
over in california recently had to
hold their little rally on a sidewalk
with just a handful of people in
attendance
so to me the most likely explanation
as to why marjorie taylor green would be
heading to the iowa state fair
is because it is essentially a captive
audience
and she is incredibly uh uh
less likely to be kicked out of it
so why not right why not go
there to this thing that everybody
focuses on especially in the world of
politics
why not go there and do your spiel in
front of these individuals
why not go out there and talk to them it
doesn't have to be a presidential run
it could just be something as simple as
oh boy
i have more people i can do my little
spiel to
i i feel like that's probably the most
likely explanation it is the simplest
explanation
she struggled to find an audience so
this would be it
but let's look at the extreme side okay
let's assume for a second
marjorie taylor green is actually um as
they call it testing the waters
for a presidential run bring it on
like i am here all day for that
marjorie taylor green won her election
in georgia last year
running unopposed getting 74
of the vote okay she couldn't even crack
a solid three-quarters of the vote
when nobody was running against her
from this tiny little georgia district
a deep red solid republican district and
she couldn't even get 75 percent
yikes not to mention the fact that she
has made a spectacle of herself
all across the country at this point
she's done it throughout all of her
media appearances
all of her horrific tweets her
anti-semitic tweets
so if she wants to run for president go
for it
i seriously doubt you have any chance
whatsoever of being successful with it
i do not believe for a second that she
could end up being you know the kind of
dark horse person like donald trump
became
you know going out and basically telling
the people what they wanted
to hear to the point where they somehow
decided to vote for him i don't think
she has that potential
because she absolutely does not have
that kind of charisma that
odd charm that kind of sucks people in
she's just a train wreck
and i don't think she she would have any
chance whatsoever
all she would do in a presidential
primary
is just drag down the overall image of
the republican party so like i said
i'm here all day for it i hope
she is going to iowa to test the waters
for a presidential run
but i also truly don't believe that
that's what she's actually doing
i'm really excited that one of our
sponsors today
is helix sleep i sleep on a helix
mattress
at home i absolutely love it and that's
why
i reached out to them about sponsoring
the david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me
i didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like
but helix has a sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their
tool matched me with a mattress that is
perfect
for me it's cool enough at night it's
the right firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years by both
gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you first
hand every helix mattress comes with a
10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video